we now revisit the polling problem that
we have studied earlier when we first
looked at that problem we used the
chebyshev inequality to obtain certain
bounds and numerical results what we
want to do now is instead to use a
central limit theorem type approximation
which we hope that it will be more
accurate and more informative let us
remind ourselves of the setting we want
to estimate a certain number P which is
the fraction of a population that will
vote yes in a certain referendum and we
estimate P by picking a sample out of
the population we pick n people we pick
them randomly uniformly over the
population and independently and for
each one of the people in the sample we
ask them if they will vote yes or no and
we record their answers in Bernoulli
random variables X I so by the
assumptions that we have made these x
i's are independent Bernoulli random
variables and their mean is equal to P
we count how many X's were equal to one
that's the number of yeses we divide by
n and that gives us the fraction in the
population that have responded yes this
is the sample mean of the XS and we use
this sample mean to estimate the unknown
fraction P we would like the error in
our estimation to be small that is the
difference between the sample mean and
the true value P to be small less let's
say than one percentage point now
there's no way of guaranteeing that this
spec will be met with certainty unless
with sample almost everyone in the
population but what we can do instead is
to ask that these specifications are
violated with only a small probability
so we look at the probability that our
estimation error is larger than what we
want this is the case that we do not
meet the specs and we would like this
probability to be small and one possible
question is what the value of n should
be in order to meet these specs
but in order to do any calculations we
first need a way of approximating this
probability and we will do that using
the central limit theorem and the
central limit theorem involves this
standardized version of the random
variable SN who are SN stands for the
sum of the XS we know that this random
variable is approximately normal and
what we want to do now is to take this
event and rewrite it in an equivalent
way but which involves this random
variable Z n so let us start first we
note that here we have a mu and the
Sigma so we should know what these are
for a Bernoulli random variable the mean
is what we already wrote down and Sigma
is the square root of P times 1 minus P
now let's look at this event MN is the
same as s n divided by n by definition
and P we can write P in this form minus
n times P divided by N and we want this
quantity to be larger than or equal to
0.01 so this event here is identical to
that event up there this starts to look
like this expression P is the same as mu
but there is a little bit of a
difference in the denominator terms so
let's see what we can do let's take this
same event but multiply both sides of
the inequality by square root of n this
causes this denominator term to become
just square root of N and we get a
square root of n term in the numerator
on the other side this is an equivalent
description of the event and now we can
multiply both sides of this inequality
by Sigma actually the denominators of
both sides by Sigma and we obtain this
equation
violent representation but now we notice
that here we do have the random variable
Z and that we wanted and so we managed
to express this event in terms of the
random variable Z n in particular what
we have is that this probability is the
same as the probability that the
absolute value of Z n is larger than or
equal to 0.01 square root of n divided
by Sigma and then we can use the central
limit theorem approximation to
approximate this probability by the
corresponding probability where we now
use a standard normal random variable
instead of the Zn random variable so
here Z stands for a standard normal
random variable with mean 0 and variance
equal to 1 let us now continue in a new
slide so that we have some working space
and here is the result that we have
derived so far if somebody gives us the
value of n we would like to be able to
calculate this probability using this
approximation however there's a slight
difficulty because Sigma is a function
that depends on P and it is not known
however as we discussed when we first
studied the polling problem we do know
that Sigma is always less than or equal
to 1/2 and this suggests that we could
use here the worst case value of the
standard deviation replace Sigma by 1/2
and instead look at this probability
here how are these two probabilities
related which direction does the
inequality go a sketch will be useful
here Z is a standard normal and it's
centered at 0 somewhere here we have a
value of 0.02 square root and
and somewhere further out we have the
value of 0.01 square root n divided by
Sigma why are these two values ordered
this way since Sigma is less than 1/2 1
over Sigma is bigger than 2 so this
expression here is bigger than this
expression there since the inequality
goes this way now we can compare these
two events this event that Z is larger
in absolute value than this number is
the probability of this tail of the
distribution and we will have a similar
probability from the other end of the
tail of the distribution here we're
talking about the probability of being
larger than or equal to this number
which would correspond only to this part
of the tail and similarly a small part
of the tail from the other side so the
blue event is smaller than the red event
this is the probability of the blue
event so it's going to be no larger than
the probability of the red event so now
if somebody gives us a value of n we
should be able to calculate this
probability how do we calculate it the
probability that the absolute value is
above a certain number is equal to the
probability of this tail plus the
probability of that tail but because of
the symmetry of the normal distribution
this is twice the probability of each
one of the tails now what is the
probability of this tail it's 1 minus
the probability of whatever is below
that so it's 1 minus and the probability
of being below that this is the standard
normal CDF evaluated at point 2 square
root N and so we do have now an
expression for the desired probability
or at least a bound for it
which is expressed in terms of the
standard normalcdf if somebody gives you
a value of n you can plug in here if n
is 10,000 then square root of n is a
hundred and this number becomes equal to
two and so in this case what we obtain
is that the probability of interest is
less than or equal to two times one
minus Phi of 2 and now we invoke the
standard normal table and from the
normal table we obtain that this
quantity is equal to twice one minus
point nine seven seven two which
evaluates to zero point zero four six
so if we use 10,000 people in our sample
then we will get an accuracy of one
percentage point with very high
probability the probability that we do
not meet the specification so that the
accuracy that we get is worse than one
percentage point that probability is
quite small it's zero point zero four
six that is four and something percent
this is pretty good and suppose that
your boss now tells you I only want the
probability of not meeting the specs to
be five percent you look at this result
and you say with ten thousand I achieved
a probability of a large error that's
less than five percent this means that I
probably have some leeway and that I can
reduce the size of my sample
what could the size of the sample be and
still meet those specs what we're trying
to do here is that we have this
approximation for the probability of
interest
and we want to set this probability to a
value of 0.05 and then we want to ask
what is the value of n that will result
in this particular probability of not
meeting the specs now we can do the
algebra and we find that this
corresponds to requiring that Phi of
0.02 square root n to be equal to 0.9 75
quite the interpretation of this we want
to choose n so that the probability of
the two tails is 5% this means that we
want this probability here to be two and
a half percent this means that the
probability of whatever is to the left
of this number should be 0.975 including
the tail this means again that we have
to look at the normal the standard
normal table and ask what's the value
for which the cdf is equal to 0.9 7-5 so
we look around and we find 0.975 to be
here and it corresponds to 1.96 so this
tells us that 0.02 square root n should
be equal to 1.96 and then we solve for n
and we find that the value of n is 9600
for which is indeed some reduction from
the 10,000 that we had originally so how
does this relate to the real world when
you read newspapers about polls you will
never see sample sizes that are about
10,000
you will usually see sample sizes of the
order of a thousand sometimes even
smaller how can they do that well they
can do that because the specs that they
impose are not as tight as the specs
that we have here usually they tell you
that the results are accurate within
three percentage points let's say
instead of one percentage point and by
moving from 0.01 to 0.03 and if you
repeat those calculations you will find
that the sample size of about a thousand
will actually do